alma ha desarrollado un nuevo tipo de
antibiótico para que el antibiótico sea
suficientemente efectivo este debe matar
por lo menos 90% de las bacterias cuando
se aplica a un cultivo de bacterias
dañinas aplicó su antibiótico a una
placa de petri lleno de bacterias
dañinas esperó a que hiciera efecto y
luego trató de estimar el porcentaje de
bacterias muertas en el tomo una muestra
al azar de 300 bacterias y encontró que
el 94 por ciento estaban muertas luego
calculó el margen de error y encontró
que es más probable que el porcentaje
real de bacterias muertas esté por
encima del 90%
lo que está pasando aquí es que ella
está intentando saber qué porcentaje de
la población total de bacterias murió y
tal vez esto es algo de esta bacteria o
quizá cuando las miras a simple vista no
puedes decir si las bacterias murieron o
no y por eso decide estimar el
porcentaje real al muestrear 300
bacterias y luego en sus muestras
encontró que el 94% de las bacterias
estaban muertas y el margen de error nos
dice ya que el margen de error nos dice
que no es común o que es muy común que
el verdadero porcentaje esté arriba del
90%
eso significa que dado que nuestro 300
bacterias es poco común que el verdadero
porcentaje esté por debajo del 90% así
que ella puede sentirse razonablemente
confiada que en su placa de petri más
del 90% de su población ha muerto
ahora respondamos estas preguntas qué
tipo de estudio estadístico uso alma
bueno ella uso ella está intentando
estimar un parámetro para una población
en este caso el parámetro es el
porcentaje de todas las bacterias que
murieron ella no pudo observar eso
directamente así que en lugar de eso
tomo una muestra al azar de las
bacterias en el plato de petri y ella
calculó estadísticas para ellas el 94%
de ellas estaban muertas y esa es
nuestra estimación para el parámetro de
la población el porcentaje de la
población que murió cuando estás usando
una muestra al azar para generar
estadísticas que estiman un parámetro
para una población ese es un estudio de
muestreo así que ella hizo un estudio de
muestreo
nuestra siguiente pregunta es el estudio
es apropiado para las preguntas
estadísticas que debe de responder así
que cuál era la pregunta que quería
responder por la manera y como está
escrita parece ser que quiere responder
si sirve o no su antibiótico si es un
antibiótico efectivo si es capaz de
matar la bacteria y podrías estar
tentado a decir bueno está bien no mira
parece que mató mató más del 99% de las
bacterias o es muy probable que matar a
más del 99% de las bacterias dado el
tamaño de la muestra y el margen de
error pero aunque realmente sea el caso
el que el 95% de las bacterias hayan
muerto no significa necesariamente que
haya sido por el antibiótico tal vez fue
debido al plástico en la placa de petri
tal vez el aire en la placa de petri
estaba muy frío o tal vez fue manipulado
en una manera poco
o tal vez esas bacterias eran sólo un
mal cultivo y de alguna manera
espontáneamente se murieron solas no
puede asegurar realmente que haya sido
el antibiótico
para que ella pueda hacer esa
declaración ella debe de hacer un
experimento adecuado ella debe de tener
un grupo de control y un grupo de
tratamiento donde todo sea igual excepto
que el grupo de tratamiento tiene el
tratamiento donde ella tenga dos placas
de petri que estén bajo las mismas
condiciones la misma iluminación el
mismo aire el mismo el mismo material en
el que está creciendo la bacteria que
todo sea igual excepto que al grupo de
tratamiento se le aplica el antibiótico
y luego ella podría ver que en el grupo
de tratamiento la mayoría de las
bacterias mueren y en el grupo de
control la mayoría de las bacterias no
entonces ella podría decir bien parece
que el antibiótico ocasionó que las
bacterias murieran así que ella tuvo que
haber hecho un experimento el estudio
estadístico apropiado o el estudio más
apropiado hubiera sido un experimento
controlado adecuadamente teniendo un
grupo de control en donde
se tiene antibióticos y un grupo de
tratamiento donde si se tiene el
antibiótico
así que veamos las opciones donde dice
que es un estudio apropiado
y porque ella utilizó no no me gusta esa
respuesta no porque ella no puede saber
realmente que el porcentaje real de
bacterias muertas está arriba del 90%
no voy a elegir esa porque aunque ella
estuviera segura de que el porcentaje de
bacterias muertas fuera de 95% ella no
puede estar segura que haya sido debido
al antibiótico una vez más pudo haber
sido por las condiciones del aire pudo
haber ocurrido por la placa de petri
pudo haber ocurrido por la iluminación
en la habitación
no porque el estudio no tiene un grupo
de tratamiento y un grupo de control
yo seleccionaría esa
sí porque ella encontró que el
antibiótico mata más del 90% de las
bacterias dañinas
una vez más aunque ella estuviera segura
de que más del 90% de la población ha
muerto ella no sabe si fue causado por
el antibiótico pudo haber sucedido por
muchas otras cosas si tienes un grupo de
control que tuvieran las mismas
condiciones y no se murieran las
bacterias entonces podría estar más
segura de que la muerte de las bacterias
fue debido al antibiótico